hey Cruz oh hey mr. sterling I'd like to
introduce you to Lightning McQueen here
you're the maestro
mr. sterling did you say Lightning
McQueen was here because I don't see him
anywhere uh but he's right here
do you not to see him nope still don't
see him it's right in front of you it's
Lightning McQueen he's obviously an
imposter
he looks old and broken-down Hey with
flabby tires I do not use that whoa oh
yeah I see I can use that energy from
motivation right it's all about
motivation mr. McQueen you can use
anything negative as fuel to push
through to the positive but pretty
positive ever since I was a rookie I am
so excited that I get to train you I
grew up watching you on TV huh is that
right these young guys are great and all
but I like a challenge
ha ha not that much older I call you my
senior project good ready for what's
coming
Jackson form is part of the next
generation of high-tech racers
rookie sensation Jackson's Tom Jackson
Storm to storm in a class of his own hey
champ
got a good run you have no idea what a
pleasure it is for me to finally beat
you did you say meet or beat I think you
heard me enjoy your retirement
you'll never be the racer you once were
you can't turn back the clock kid but
you can wind it up again the racing
world is changing treadmills wind
tunnels virtual reality still working on
that and interactive race simulation
whoa I've jumped the barrier you have
crash we got some work to do I am so
excited that I get to train visualize
speeding
[Music]
the beach ate me every week veteran
racers retire to make room for these
younger faster racers questions
paparazzi you'll never be as fast to
storm but you can be smarter
good luck out there you're gonna need it
I decide when I'm done
you are not winning this
coming for you storm
[Applause]
[Music]